>> Mario: Hello. Good afternoon everyone.
My name is Mario [inaudible]. I'm originally
from Mexico and I work in Platforms here as
a software engineer. This is part of my 20
percent and today we have a great speaker.
Just to give you a little bit of background,
a couple of Googlers got together about a
year ago and we said, "Why can't we do different
at Google to spread role models?" And it was
very, very easy we say, "Why don't we invite
them to speak at Google and we put them on
YouTube."
And we created a channel and we have tons
of visitors, but today we are really, really
honored just not to have a role model, but
one of the greatest role models in the Hispanic
community.
And today we hope you enjoy this talk. You
still can go go/nasatalkquestion to ask questions
on Dory. We have about 25 offices most of
North America, Mexico City, São Paulo, Belo
Horizonte, and-and Buenos Aires that are also
listening to this talk remotely. So feel free
to ask questions.
We also have a couple of live questions at
the end. The time is very short at the end
so feel free to-to go to Dory if you can.
And today we have an-an honor to introduce
him, but in order to do so I'm going to hand
off the mic to two great Googlers, one of
them is Tiffany Montague. She runs all of
our space related programs. She's going to
talk a little bit about that and then Gonzalo
Begazo is one of the founders of SEN. He's
going to introduce the speaker today.
So I hope you really enjoy this talk.
[applause]
>>Tiffany Montague: Thank you Mario.
My name's Tiffany Montague. I manage our Space
Initiative. Some of you might know me by my
moment title which is the Commander of the
Universe.
[laughter]
I-I used my incredible space powers today
to summon actually not one but two astronauts.
We have two astronauts here, Yvonne Cagle.
[applause]
I-I've always known that I wanted to be involved
in the space business. In fact prior to Google
I was in the space field. I was flying in
a high altitude airplane as a flight test
engineer at Johnson Space Center.
I even applied for astronaut training twice
and I didn't make it and I was heartbroken
for about a day until I realized that there
were two ways into the space community: one,
NASA, the government and two, commercial space.
And that's partly why Google is involved in-in
the Space Initiatives.
I've spent the fast, past several years cultivating
some space projects that you are probably
familiar with: one, our relationship with
NASA, two, the Google Lunar X PRIZE.
In the past 12 months alone we have launched
some amazing products with NASA: Google Moon;
Google Mars.
And the Google Lunar X PRIZE is well on its
way to success. I think it'll be won before
2015 and we have 22 teams, 22 global teams
from around the world who are competing in
a race to the moon.
So why is Google involved in these space projects?
Well, we are all technologists, all scientists,
all engineers, and most of us are space enthusiasts,
right? Yeah.
We are also really strong supporters of openness:
open source, open Internet. Why not open access
to space, right?
In the case of Google Lunar X PRIZE it's the
largest incentive prize ever offered and the
goal is not just technical achievement and
the demonstration of lunar capability, it's
investing in a future technological work force.
And it's demonstrating a new space economy.
And in my short conversation with Jose earlier
today I learned that he shares those goals.
But to do that we need to first remove this
mental log jam that exists about the access
to space; about whether it's possible to go
to space and not be a government.
We need to fundamentally change the public's
perceptions about space exploration so that
they know space should be open and accessible
to everyone.
And I don't know about you, but when I was
a kid I was promised that in the future we
would have robots and jet packs and we'd all
be vacationing on the moon. Well it's 2010
and I'm ready.
[laughter]
So, I hope all this happens in our lifetimes,
in my lifetime specifically. Otherwise we're
gonna need a prize for cryogenics.
[laughter]
And with that I'll hand it off to my colleague
Gonzalo.
[applause]
>>Gonzalo Begazo: Thank you very much, Tiffany.
Hi everyone. My name is Gonzalo Begazo, I'm
Director of Accounting and on behalf of Google
and the Hispanic Google Network I'm extremely
happy to introduce you, Mr. Jose Hernanez.
Jose's an engineer and also a NASA astronaut.
He was born in California a Mexican descendant
and as a child he worked alongside his family
and other farm workers in the fields of California
moving from one town to another harvesting
crops. He did not learn to speak English until
he was 12 years old.
It was until he was 41 that NASA finally accepted
him into the Astronaut Training Program and
later assigned him to the crew of the Space
Shuttle Mission STS-128.
Jose also served as a chief of the materials
and processes branch of Johnson Space Center
and received recognition for his work at Lawrence
Livermore National Laboratory where he co-developed
the first full field digital mammography imaging
system proven to detect breast cancer at an
earlier stage than previous techniques.
He also worked in the international arena
where he represented Lawrence Livermore and
the U.S. Department of Energy in-on Russian
nuclear non-prof, non-proliferation issues.
He earned a BS in electrical engineering from
the University of the Pacific, and MS in electrical
and computer engineering from the University
of California Santa Barbara and, where he
was also awarded an honorary doctor of law
degree in 2006.
Jose created the Jose Hernandez Reaching for
the Stars Foundation in December 2005, a non-profit
organization.
Having been raised by parents in-in a migrant
jet [inaudible] family, Jose believes that
all children despite family challenges should
have the same educational opportunities he
did.
Inspired by Dr. Franklin Chang-Diaz who in
the 19, in the 1980's became the first Hispanic-American
astronaut, Jose now wants children to also
become inspired to learn more about math and
science.
With that please let me introduce you Mr.
Jose Hernandez.
[applause]
>>Jose Hernandez: Thank you, thank you Gonzalo
for that kind introduction.
And Tiffany I think Lockheed Martin just announced
that they have their commercial jet packs.
[laughter]
They're a little expensive right now, but
I think, I think, I think they're developing
it pretty good and-and Mario, thank you very
much and to the whole Hispanic Googlers Network
for extending this invitation; also to my
colleague Yvonne Cagle from NASA Ames. She's
the one that actually put us in contact and
she sent me the original email and of course
when they said, "Google," I said, "Hey, I-I'm
interesting in seeing what you guys are doing
over here."
And let me tell 'ya I spent the whole morning
here and-and I wanna come work with you guys.
[laughter]
I mean this is, it's a, it's a neat place.
You think NASA's neat, you guys, you guys,
have it all man. It-it is neat.
I think my colleague Ed Lu already beat me
to it though. I think you guys already have
your-your quota of one astronaut so whenever
he moves on just make sure you guys give me
a call, alright?
But this is gonna be a little bit like church,
okay?
[laughter]
I-I have, I have, I have a treat for you guys
at the very end, but first you gotta listen
to the sermon.
[laughter]
Okay?
The treat, the treat at the very end, its
gonna be, I have about an 18 minute video
that summarizes my mission from last year.
It was aboard, on board STS-128 Discovery
and it was from August 28th of last year through
September 11th. And we went all the way up
to the International Space Station, connected
with them, and we formed a-a group of seven
of us from-from my crew and six from the station,
the 13 of us were up in space simultaneously,
which was somethin' very incredible.
But-but before I do that I-I think I need
to tell ya a little bit about myself so that,
so that you guys can better appreciate what-what-what
you guys are to the community, be, like it
or not I think you guys are-are role models
to our community.
And-and I'm sure the 80/20 that you guys have
the ability here a lot of you choose to use
that 20 to go out in the community and do
some good in terms of influencing our kids
to get into science, technology, engineering,
and math; get into the STEM fields. And I
think that is, that is very important.
I think the-the-the, I was listening to-to
the White House when they were, they had this
event for community colleges and I think it
was Joe Biden said some quote that really
stuck to me and-and that is the-the-the "countries
that out educate us today are gonna out compete
us tomorrow."
And it's very important that we engage our
kids into the STEM fields if were gonna remain
competitive on a global basis. And so-so that's
sort of the soapbox that I'm gonna get into
that you guys are gonna have to put up with
for the next 15-20 minutes and then, and then
I'll give you guys the treat, alright?
As was mentioned I come from a typical migrant
farm working family. I'm first generation.
I was born here in the States and-and so you
would say, "Well, what's a typical migrant
farm working family?" And let me, let me paint
the scenery for you. It's actually quite simple.
My parents came from Michaocan, the state
of Michaocan in Mexico. If you, if you balance
Mexico on a pin that center of mass there,
that's where Michaocan's at. So we're dead
center in Mexico.
And every year my Dad would-would load up
the kids in the car, there was four of us,
and I was the youngest one, would load up
the kids in the car, Mom as well and we would
make a two day trip through Mexico, Northern
Mexico all the way up to Southern California.
We would reach Ontario near Los Angeles and
we would spend about a month and a half there
picking strawberries. That's how we would
start the season.
Then about month and a half later we would
drive up to Salinas and then we would pick
lechuga which is the lettuce. We would work
in the hoe, hoeing with respect to thinning
out sugar beets and whatever it was they were
planting.
And then after that we would then two months
later move up to the Stockton area; Stockton,
Tracy, Modesto. And we would hang out here
the bulk of our time; start working in picking
cucumbers, tomatoes, cherries, anything that
was in season we picked it.
And then after that November would roll around
and now we would make what would be a two
and half day trip back to Mexico. And we would
cool our heels between November and February
in Mexico and then that process would begin
again and we would do that year after year.
So you can see that that is why it took me
until I was 12 years old to dominate the English
language. I mean while we was being pulled
out from different school districts throughout
the year and-and so there was very little
stability.
And-and-and-and so I remember, I remember
that-that-that one thing that my parents did
different than what a typical migrant farm
working family was in spite of their third
grade education, was that they put a lot of
emphasis in education. They didn't understand
it, but they knew it was something good.
And so Monday through Friday where ever we
were we were in school. And Saturday and Sunday
rolled around where ever we were we were working
right aside Mom and Dad in the fields trying'
to supplement the family income.
And-and-and while a lot of kids looked forward
to summer vacation, the Hernandez kids kinda
hated summer vacation 'cause we knew what
that signified --
[laughter]
that represented we had to be out there in
the fields seven days a week so that was no
fun.
I-I also remember, I also remember that my
parents were very, very smart. I swear they
would have made great psychologists 'cause-'cause
one of the things that they always did is
they did little things that kinda had a lot
of strong, a strong message with respect to
education.
I remember every day when we used to, it almost
turned out to be a game, but-but whenever
we used to go home after a long day's work,
for example if we were picking cucumbers you
wear Levis and they get muddy in the morning
and then they dry up during the day, the sun
bakes 'em. I remember when we used to go home
us kids used to play games see who could make
their Levis stand up on themselves.
[laughter]
And we used to kid around that that's the
person that worked the hardest that day, but
actually it's, I always won 'cause I was always
rolling around in the mud 'cause I was the
youngest one, right so.
But anyway I remember every day my Dad used
to, we used to get in the back seat of the
car after a long day's work, we were hot,
sweaty, dusty, and before he start the car
and like I said we used to, we used to make
this a game 'cause we said, "He's gonna forget
today. He's gonna forget." And before he put
the key in the ignition he would look back
and say, "How do you guys feel today?" And
that was the message all, every day. And of
course we would always say, "Well we're tired."
And he'd say, "Well good." He says, "Remember
this feeling 'cause if you don't go to school
so I'm not gonna force you to go to school,
but if you don't go to school, get good grades,
this is what you're gonna do the rest of your
life." And so it was pretty, a pretty powerful
message.
Also I remember each time we came home from
school, each time we came home from school
my Mom would always sit us on the kitchen
table while she made her homemade tortillas
and-and food for us to eat after school, she-she
made sure that we finished our homework.
And she helped us with our homework up to
the third grade. After the third grade since
that's all she went to school for I mean she
couldn't help us anymore.
But it only took me once though I figured
out she was smart enough not to, not to help
us, but she was smart enough to realize that
we, if we, to know if we finished our homework
or not. 'Cause it only took me one test --
[laughter]
to test her out on that and a visit with the
belt to-to --
[laughter]
Not-not try it again. So I made sure I-I did
finish my homework every day.
But-but-but things, that's how it was when
I was in, was small as-as I remember it.
And things actually changed a bit when I was,
when I was in about in second grade.
I mentioned I'm, I was the youngest in the
family and I was in the second grade and November
rolled around and it was time to go to Mexico,
right? And we, here we were in Stockton and-and
my teacher tell, my Dad tells me, "Hey we're
gettin' ready to go to Mexico," like he always
did every year. "Get three months worth of
homework," 'cause when we went to Mexico we
self-studied ourselves. We did our own homework
since Christmas vacation was around the corner
and it wasn't worth it for us to go to school
in Mexico, so we took three months worth of
homework.
And so I said, "Okay that's fine." So I went
to school that day and I talked to my teacher
Mrs. Yung, a-a young Chinese teacher; she
was real tall, well I mean tall for a second
grader 'cause she's actually short, but-but
to a second grader she looked --
[laughter]
she looked tall to me and anyway a beautiful
young Chinese teacher and-and I told Mrs.
Yung I said, "Mrs. Yung we're gonna to Mexico.
Can I have my three months' worth of homework?"
And-and then she looked at me and her eyes
rolled, she rolled her eyes and of course
she had been through this routine with my
three other siblings 'cause they'd been through
the second grade. So she knew the routine.
But this time she said, "You know what? Tell
your Dad and Mom that I'm coming home today
to visit them." And I said, "Oh, okay."
So that day I ran home. We lived about a mile
and a half from school. You crossed railroad
tracks, packing sheds, and all that and in
those days you could walk to school for a
mile and a half. I guess these days you'll
get arrested for child abuse if you let your
kid --
[laughter]
your kid walk a mile and a half to school,
right? But in those days it was alright.
I remember I ran that day as fast as I could
and I told my par, my parents I said, "Hey
the-the teacher's gonna come today." And of
course you get two separate reactions from
your parents, right?
[laughter]
The first reaction is your Dad. First thing
he starts doing, he starts taking off his
belt --
[laughter]
and says, "Alright boy, what'd you do?"
And I, I tell him, "I didn't do anything.
I promise." He said, "You know it's gonna
be twice as bad if she tells me what you did
--
[laughter]
if you don't tell me, right?"
[laughs] And I said, "I-I promise. I think
it has to do with Mexico." And he said, "Okay,
you better be right boy." He said, "You better
be right."
[laughter]
I say, "Yeah."
And of course the other reaction's completely
opposite from the Mom, right? Mom, and if
you're Hispanic you would understand this
more, I think. But you get that home alone
reaction from Mom. "The teacher's coming?
We gotta clean the house!"
[laughter]
"We gotta cook a feast 'cause la maestra is
coming." It's, the Hispanics have this big
respect for educators and so, and so-so all
the bells and whistles come out when they
figure that the maestra was coming.
And as I remember she came, we ate very good,
I-I remember even telling my teacher, Mrs.
Yung, I said, "You oughta come more often."
[laughter]
'Cause we ate so well that day. And-and-and
so, and so, and so she came and after-after
dinner and everything in her words and-and
I remember she used terms that my parents
could understand because I was sort of helped
interpret and-and she basically told my parents,
she said, "Hey you guys oughta stay in one
place. Don't live a nomadic life. Set root
in one place so the trees can grow strong."
And obviously the trees were the kids; the
four kids 'cause she had had all four kids.
And she said, "Look your kids, I've had all
four of them they're-they're kind of bright
and if you give 'em a chance they can be something
when they grow up."
And my parents to again, to their credit they-they-they
actually took that advice. I mean We still
went to Mexico that year, but we instead of
coming back to Ontario and doing the-the migrant
thing, we went straight to Stockton. And we
started making Stockton our home.
And then our three month trips started shrinking
to about three weeks centered around Christmas
holidays so we didn't miss a lot of school.
And that's when our education started to get
traction. And it was, it was also the fact
that my parents, my Mom like I said she would
have made a great psychologist, I mean she
also put the burden on us with respect to
gettin' an education 'cause she, she would
never say, "Oh you know I hope you guys go
to college. I hope you guys are gonna do this."
She always said, "When." She sort of set that
bit in our brain and she always said it was
expected.
We didn't know any better even though they
only went to the third grade, we knew we had
to go to college else our, we were gonna have
to answer with our parents, to our parents.
So-so-so that's when we started gettin' traction
in our education 'cause we started gettin'
a little bit more stability.
And I-I guess the other thing, the question
would-would say is well then how was it that
you actually became an astronaut? Or what-what
made you become an astronaut?
And I think I could point to three events
in my life that sort of took me to that, to
that, to that point or to this road that I'm
now walking on.
The first, I think I have to give thanks to
my migrant farm working background because
I remember as a kid when we used to go work
in the fields we used to go in the darkness
of night right before dawn, before the sun
comes up. You drive out to the fields.
So you go out in country away from light pollution
and my favorite part of the, of the trip was
when we got there I was able to get out, it
was dark and I could look up and no light
pollution from city lights or anything and
you could see the dark sky. And you could
see the stars and they were, they almost like
in 3D they were so clear. And-and so I just
had that attraction to it. Probably didn't
hurt the fact that Star Trek was on during
that time.
[laughter]
But-but-but-but really that's what attracted
me.
And then, and then the next one was when I
was about 10 years old. Unfortunately I'm
old enough to remember the-the tail end of
the Apollo program and I remember Apollo 17
very clear.
We, as you guys are know or oh yeah you guys
are so young you guys wouldn't know, but-but-but
you guys may have read in the history books,
how's that?
[laughter]
When there was an Apollo mission and there
was a moon walk they would preempt programming
on TV and you would have folks like Walter
Cronkite narrate the moon walk.
And of course the very last mission Apollo
17, everybody-everybody would stop and watch
the mission and-and everybody in the U.S.
and the world I imagine. And the Hernandez
family was no different.
Only difference is the fact that we had an
old black and white TV and I'm not sure if
you guys have seen pictures of those old black
and white TV's, but they're those big consoles
like a piece of furniture. They have a screen
in the middle and integrated speakers, four
little legs and a big honking knob to change
the channel. That was our TV.
Only difference with ours was that ours was
black and white and-and snowy picture. And
I remember sometimes you'd lose that horizontal
sync, you get that bar in the picture, and
so the only way to fix it is you hit it on
the side and then it would stop. Now that
was our TV.
And at that time there wasn't any satellite
TV programming, but we did have cable TV,
but God forbid we have cable 'cause we couldn't
afford it so we have the next best thing.
We had what was called rabbit ear antennas
to increase reception on top of the TV.
And so of course whenever something important
came on the family wanted a nice clear picture,
right? So guess who they called to adjust
the TV? I was, since I was the youngest one,
right, I was the official channel changer.
And I know, I know now why this happens but
'cause I'm an electrical engineer, but as
soon as I grabbed the antennae guess what
happened? The picture would improve, right?
[laughter]
And guess what my Dad would say? "Stay there."
So-so here I am in a contortionists mode trying
to watch-watch TV while tryin' to keep Mom
and Dad and my, the rest of my siblings happy
and them watching a good, a good picture,
right? And-and I also remember, I also remember
whenever we needed to change the channel guess
who the official channel changer was? It was
yours truly, as well.
And I remember one day when-when-when I went
up for the umpteenth time to change the channel
my, I figured I'd say okay I'm gonna say somethin'
very subtle to my Dad 'cause you had to understand
my Dad. You can't, you can't direct him to
do anything or you'll get yourself slapped.
But-but I would say I'm gonna do somethin'
very political and just kinda say it very
subtle as-as he sent me for the twelfth time
to change the channel that day.
I said, "Hey Dad you know you know they have
those new TVs now that have remote control
and they're color too." And-and then so I
went quickly, I said I'm gonna go quickly
and change the channel so he doesn't get mad
at me. So I changed it. And then I went back
and sat down and then he stood up and he looked
at me and he kinda like a little pitiful little
shake in his head --
[laughter]
He says, "Son", he says, "why do I need a
remote control when I have you?"
[laughter]
And then he said, "You-you want color?" He
says, "You want color?" He says, "Use your
imagination that way you can put any color
you want."
[laughter]
That's that.
So he had a practical answer for that. We
kept our TV for the, for the next few years
until it finally went out. That's when we
got a new one.
But-but I remember the images, the images
that we saw on TV of the astronauts walking
on the moon. I remember seeing them so vividly.
It's one-sixth the gravity so when they were
walking in their space, in their, in their
lunar suits jumping and doing slow motion
maneuvers it's, it kinda like captivated me.
I sat down in front and watched.
Then I would go outside and I would see the
moon up there and I would stare at it for
a few minutes, come back and watch, watch
'em again on TV. And then I would do that
about four or five times.
And that's when the-the actual idea for me
came to say, "You know that's what I wanna
be. I wanna be an astronaut."
I'm sure every nine, ten year old kid at that
age wanted to be an astronaut too.
And that's the other thing I gotta give credit
to my parents, is I shared that dream with
them and instead of them saying, "Hey you're
shootin' too high. Maybe you oughta just think
about finishing high school going to college,"
they actually nurtured that dream.
That's why I think they would have made good
psychologists 'cause they-they fed that dream,
they nurtured it. They said, "Anything's possible
in this country," they said. "Just get yourself
a good education and work hard. You put those
two ingredients together you can do whatever
you want."
I'm sure knowing-knowing how my Dad is, I'm
sure what he was thinking behind in the back
of his head he was probably saying, "Poor
guy doesn't stand a chance, but let's not
burst his bubble."
[laughter]
But-but no, but they actually, they actually
did nurture-nurture that dream and that's-that's
when at the same time my education started
to gain traction.
So the third part, the third event that sort
of what I call "sealed the deal" for me to
become an astronaut was when I was a senior
in high school. And that was when I heard
over the radio that some guy named Franklin
Chang hyphen Diaz got selected as the first
Hispanic astronaut. And I said, "Wow." I said,
"Chang," okay I wasn't too crazy about the
Chang part but --
[laughter]
But the Diaz, I could relate to the Diaz.
I mean that's like Hernandez. And so I started
reading about him. I started reading about
him and you know what I found out? I found
out that there was many similarities between
him and I. He came from a humble background
from Costa Rica. He had brown skin like me.
He spoke English with an accent like me. Yet
he was a U.S. astronaut.
And so I kinda got jealous. Jealous in a good
way 'cause I said, "You know if he was able
to do it, why can't I do it?" And that sort
of empowered me.
And that goes back to what you guys are here.
You guys are also role models in your community.
That if folks go out there, young kids go
out there and see you, and you see kids like
you, you empower them to say, "He looks just
like me. He was able to do it. Why can't I
do it?"
And that, I think that's what's important.
And so that's when I made the personal promise
to myself to-to get selected and work as an
astronaut.
And so I went to college, Pacific. You guys
heard my-my-my background in my work. I went
Pacific, went to graduate school at Santa
Barbara, and then started working down the
road here at Lawrence Livermore National Lab.
I worked here 14 years at Lawrence Livermore
Lab.
And I started applying to NASA. And-and Tiffany
I applied 12 times. Twelve years in a row.
So the-the-the other key is perseverance;
it's perseverance. 'Cause I applied the first
six years, I would just get a thanks, a postcard
saying, "We received your application. Don't
call us; we'll call you" kind of thing.
[laughter]
And-and-and-and so I just started building
my career, my curriculum and started gettin'
work of becoming a pilot, scuba diver, and
doing work related to the space industry.
And that's, six years into the process I got
my first call.
And the selection process is, is actually
pretty simple; gettin' selected is the tough
part, but the process is pretty simple.
It-it-it's basically there's over 4,000 people
that apply each year and they don't select
a class every year. They'll select it every
two or four years.
And what they do is they review those 4,000
and then after that they'll select about 300
where they'll take a closer look at your application.
If you have technical publications they'll
ask for 'em so they can read 'em. They'll
talk to your boss.
After those 300 are reviewed they'll down
select to 100. What I call "the 100 lucky
ones." Because these 100 whenever there's
a selection that year get invited to spend
a week at NASA, the Johnson Space Center.
And there you spend one week where you go
through a series of psychological tests and
make sure that you're not crazy and obviously
we need some improvement in that process.
[laughter]
And-and-and also-also they go very detailed
medical exams and I mean very detailed and
I'm not sure if any, if there's any males
over 40 but if-if you are over 40 you know
what I'm talking about.
[laughter]
And then, and then, and then, and then it
ends, it ends with a, it ends with a-a series
of interviews with a panel of about 12 to
18 people. A lot of 'em sittin' astronauts.
And then after that everybody goes home.
And then from there about 20 percent get medically
disqualified, usually eyesight, somethin'
wrong with their ticker, or hearing's not
up to standards that they need.
And so from those 80, they'll probably select
about 40 to do a-a serious medical, I mean
a serious security background check; make
sure you're paying your taxes, you're a good
citizen and all that.
From those 40 then they'll select anywhere
from 10 to 18 astronauts for that particular
class.
And that's how the process is.
So year six was my first year that I got invited.
I was made it to that 100 and to that 80,
to that 40, and then guess what? I didn't
get selected. So that was in '98, right '98.
So I had to wait another two years. I kept
applying, kept applying.
And then in 2000 again I made it to the 100,
80, 40. This time I didn't tell a lot of people
'cause then I didn't have to explain a lot
as to why I didn't get selected. And it was
a good thing I didn't because I didn't get
selected.
[laughter]
And so, and so once again it, after eight
years of applying and two interviews, I came
out empty handed. So I just kept applying.
Four years later I was invited before those
four years after the eighth year I was invited
to come and work at NASA as an engineer. I
worked there and then four years later they
did another selection round and, which is
my twelfth year in the whole process. And
that's when I finally got selected. That was
2004.
So-so what happens then is-is your class shows
up from all over the country; they come from
all walks of life. They're researchers, they're
engineers, they're doctors, geologists, from
the military. And they show up as a class
and they start training.
So we train, 'cause obviously we're not, we're
not qualified to for a space, be assigned
to a space mission so we train for two years.
Once you finish the training then you get
a technical assignment and then you get assigned
to a mission.
So that's what happened to me. I showed up
at 2004; trained for two years; 2006 had a
technical assignment; and then in 2008 I got
assigned to a mission. And then last year
was when the mission was fully realized.
And so-so-so the mission that we got selected,
that I got selected for was STS-128. The actual,
usually it doesn't match up that well, but
in this particular case it did match up very
well; 128 stands for the hundredth and twenty-eighth
mission of the Space Shuttle Fleet. And it
was aboard Discovery.
I was the flight engineer because and I think
it the coolest position because I sit right
behind the-the commander and the pilot kind
of like in the middle and I have the best
seat of the house 'cause it's the panoramic
view is what I call it as we take off into
space.
The Mission Specialist Number One is to my
right and then, so that's four of us on the
flight deck.
And then on the mid-deck you'll-you'll see
we'll have three astronauts there. Those are
usually our space walkers 'cause they don't
have any responsibilities during our ascent
or descent of our mission, and so they're
just sittin' there as passengers in the mid-deck.
And then what you're gonna see is you're gonna
see the-the actual launch sequence of our
mission.
We launched after several scrubs, we launched
on August 28th about 11:30 at night; it was
a night launch.
And you're gonna see how-how the launch goes,
the sequence goes. You're gonna see the three
engines light up.
Inside the way it feels is you-you hear the
engines light up, you feel this gentle vibration
as you're sittin' there, you've been up there
for about three hours so you're ready to go.
And--
[laughter]
and believe me you're up there for three hours,
right? And one of the things I wanna tell
you is that you don't wanna screw up because
if you launch you know that in eight and a
half minutes you're up in space and you can
go to the restroom and activate the restroom
and go to the restroom up there.
Whereas if they scrub, you gotta wait another
hour and half be-before they finally extract
you so you can go to the restroom.
[laughter]
So-so you're always crossing your fingers,
"I hope we launch. I hope we launch."
[laughter]
And-and so, and so the way the launch sequence
goes is-is-is they light up the three rocket,
the three engines, you feel the vibration,
and then about two seconds later the two solid
rocket boosters light up.
The-the noise level goes up in order of magnitude,
the vibration is more violent. Just when you
think the whole thing is gonna fall to one
side and fall over, you feel a push in your
back and you're off to the races.
You're up, you're up accelerating and those
two solid rocket boosters are only, they provide
the thrust, the major thrust at the beginning.
They're only lit up for two and half minutes.
In two and half minutes explosive bolts separate
them, parachutes come out on them, and they're
recovered in the ocean by a boat that's waitin'
for them.
The three engines are fed by the-the main
tank, the central tank that the big tank.
It's actually two little tanks that-that-that
has liquid oxygen and liquid hydrogen and
they're feeding the three engines and they
go on for another six minutes.
And then, and-and at that point you're going
17,500 miles an hour; you're up about 280-300
miles up above, and you're going around the
world every 90 minutes.
And so we were up there 14 days. I, we went,
which meant we went around the world 217 times,
about 5.7 million miles. I wish we had frequent
flies with programs --
[laughter]
with the airlines 'cause then there would
be, I would be sittin' pretty.
But-but-but you'll see us. We rendezvoused
with the International Space Station; physically
docked to them, docked with them and then,
and did our work, and then undocked and came
back home.
And so we start the video you can see what
--
[pause]
The first thing you're gonna see is you're
gonna see our mission patch. That's the first
order of business of any new crew. You gotta
have a patch and you gotta design it and of
course everybody's last name is on there and
there was seven of us.
We had three main objectives and I'll explain
'em as we go along.
But right now the mission director is giving
our commander the go ahead to go and launch.
If-if the volume can go up.
>>Mission Director:[unintelligible] Mother
Nature is cooperating so it looks like [unintelligible]
We wish you and your team good luck and Godspeed.
[pause]
>>unidentified voice: Godspeed, NASA, caption
and the crew of Discovery. Thank you everyone
who helped [unintelligible]. I'm gonna step
up the signs on the International Space Station.
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible]
Roger.
[unintelligible]
>>unidentified voice: Discovery, roger. [unintelligible]
>>Jose Hernandez: This is the mid-deck guys;
the three of 'em.
[unintelligible]
That's the three engines lighting up.
[sound of Shuttle taking off]
And the solid rocket boosters.
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible] five,
six, seven [unintelligible]
>>unidentified voice: This is Discovery all
program.
[sound of Shuttle taking off]
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible] Discovery.
>>Jose Hernadez: The first four minutes is
like an eticket ride in Disneyland. It's actually
pretty-pretty neat.
The second four and a half minutes the g-forces
start building up and-and it feels --
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible] Alright.
>>Jose Hernadez: and it feels like first you
have a newborn baby on-on your chest and that
baby grows to like a 600 pound gorilla 'cause
you-you have trouble breathing.
There you see the two solid rocket motors
separating.
>>unidentified voice: Assist is just kickin'
off.
>>Jose Hernandez: The-the exhaustion of the
three engines continuing on.
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible] Copy,
Jose.
[pause]
>>unidentified voice: There it is.
>>Jose Hernandez: It's-it's the exhaust --
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible] your
seat if you want to, do it.
>>Jose Hernandez: And right there you saw
the explosive bolts for the separation.
>>unidentified voice: Alright. Good job.
>>unidentified voice: Thanks. [unintelligible]
I'm waitin' for the twenty second flood decks.
>>Jose Hernandez: Next up you're gonna see
is the separation from the external tank.
The external tank is not, is not recoverable;
it breaks up into pieces as it enters the
atmosphere.
>>unidentified voice: Started it at 56. I
will release it at 16 after.
[pause]
>>Jose Hernadez: And then in eight and a half
minutes we reach MECO, which is called main
engine cut off. And there you can see that's
me, that's waving there saying, "Hey, I can't
believe we reached space here." Let me, being
the good engineer and scientist that I am,
"Let me do a test here." And first thing I
do is I throw somethin' say, "Does this thing
float?"
[laughter]
I said, "I guess we are in space."
One of our objectives was to take one of our
crew mates, Nicole Stott, up to the International
Space Station. We were gonna leave her up
there for three months and bring back someone
who had been up there for three months.
The, once we get up there one of the first
things we do is we open up the payload bay
doors. We do that because the radiators are
on the inside portion of the payload bay doors;
they provide the cooling to our electronics
equipment so it's very important we do that
first.
And then the folks that were down in the mid-deck;
three folks that were down in the mid-deck
start cleaning up the mid-deck. They remove
and fold the chairs they were on and start
making room.
There's Danny Olivas, he's from El Paso. And
they activate the galley and they activate
the restroom, which you see right there.
And-and-and then I myself start puttin' together
the portable on-board computers. And these
are the ones that are gonna help up during
the rendezvous with the International Space
Station.
Our Commander C.J. Sturckow, he's the last
one to get out of his pressure suit. While
he does that other folks and I'm puttin' the
computers together; other folks are puttin'
other pieces of equipment together including
the psychoergometer. Remember that there's
zero-g, you're in micro-g environment so we
have to keep our legs muscles strong so we
exercise every day; there's a protocol.
Every morning we do the same thing we do at
home with respect to hygiene. We brush our
teeth, we, those of us that need it, we shave.
And-and then we look at what our day's assignment
is for-for that day.
One of, the next day we do what's called an
orbital maneuver system burn, OMS burn, that
bring us closer to the International Space
Station for our rendezvous.
There you see Nicole Stott with her binoculars
looking at what's gonna be her home for the
next three months. That's about 20 miles away
as she was looking at it.
And of course we get closer and closer. When
we get about 600 feet we do a maneuver what's
called a flip maneuver where the station folks
are taking pictures of our underbelly.
This is the perspective of the station crew
as they see us approaching the-the International
Space Station.
We stop; we do the maneuver; they take high
resolution pictures and that's to make sure
we didn't suffer any damage on our thermal
protection system, our belly, during ascent.
Once we're cleared for that then they give
us the go ahead for Prox Ops, Proximity Operations.
And this requires a lot of high level crew
resource management as we get in closer and
closer into the, onto the International Space
Station and basically dock, physically dock
with them.
>>unidentified voice: Maybe about point oh
six.
>>unidentified voice: Here comes a [unintelligible]
>>unidentified voice: Okay.
>>unidentified voice: Get it back --
>>unidentified voice: Yeah. That's okay. Yeah.
>>unidentified voice: Good, a firm idea of
what it is.
>>unidentified voice: Exactly Techs warned
us about that.
>>unidentified voice: Okay.
>>unidentified voice: I think you got it up
to about --
>>Jose Hernadez: During docking our commander
is the one that's in control. The pilot's
giving him cues and I'm down at the computers
giving them the-the rates which is the, which
is the speed at which we're closing in; the-the
distance –
>>unidentified voice: Overlap.
>>Jose Hernandez: and trajectory.
[pause]
And you'll see when we finally bump into the
Station, you'll see us bump right there.
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible] fired.
>>Jose Hernandez: At this point now we're
waiting for the latches to latch onto the
Station and then we're gonna get some confirming
cues, some lights that tell us that capture
is confirmed.
>>unidentified voice: Alright.
>>unidentified voice: Alright. Yeah.
[astronauts clapping]
>>various voices: Yea!!!! Alright! Good job!
>>Jose Hernandez: We're happy that we didn't
bounce off of the Station. This allows us
to open our-our-our door that has access to
the Station.
The Station folks do the same thing at their
end and there's a little a vestibule that
basically serves as the interface between
us and the International Space Station.
So-so-so now the crew on the other side, Gennady
Padelka was the commander, Russian. He rings
the door, the-the bell that basically announces
the arrival of a new crew.
[sound of bell ringing]
And so there's six of them there and seven
of us. So that's 13 astronauts at once in
space representing five countries. So truly
a international affair there of-of us working
together.
You see how happy there, they are of seeing
us. And I can tell you that they're happy
not because we're such good buds, but these
guys have been up there for about three or
four months eating a bunch of dehydrated food
and they know we've got fresh vegetables and
fruit --
[laughter]
So-so they're saying, "Oh yeah. What kind
of food did you bring?"
[laughter]
One of the second objectives, the second objective
of us was to take out the MPLM, Multi-Purpose
Logistics Module which is basically a small
portable lib, portable laboratory. It's more
like a storage thing than anything where we-we
pick it up out of the payload bay door with
the robotic arm and then we install it on
one of the ports of the Station. And you can
see Kevin Ford had the honors of doing that.
I had the honors of de-installing it and putting
it back into the, onto the Shuttle.
And once we do that it allows our colleagues
to actually open the door from the inside
of this MPLM and it gives us access to inside
of it.
You can see us wearing goggles and masks because
for the first time someone's going in there
in a zero-g environment. So there could be
metal shavings, dust particulates, and it's
not until the filtering system catches all
that that we're allowed to go in there without
any protection.
Once we're allowed to go in there we begin
the sequence of-of basically transferring
over seven tons of material from that Multi-Purpose
Logistics Module onto the International Space
Station.
And then we transfer about one ton of material
back in which includes trash and any equipment
that they no longer need on the Station.
Nicole here you can see her take a, an experiment
that she started on the Shuttle and transfers
it to the Station because it's her experiment
and she's gonna stay on the Station for the
next three months, so all her experiments
travel with her as well. And so here we are
puttin' that together.
Here you see us having a meeting. Really orientation
is not an issue 'cause there is no right up
or down so we basically meet in any orientation.
[laughter]
And we're just discussing what we're gonna
to be doing the next day.
And of course the next day is our first space
walk. The first space walk was conducted by
Danny Olivas and Nicole Stott.
And-and you see Tim Kopra there. He's the
one we traded for. He's the one that came
home with us.
But he and I have the dubious honor of making
sure that these guys put on their space suits
correctly because if you, if you see if you
realize the space suit is the only thing that's
gonna be keeping them alive. That's their
space ship once they do their space walk.
And we gotta make sure that the-the helmets
are well sealed, the gloves, the boots are
well sealed, the life support system is working
properly, the computers are working properly,
communications working properly, the cameras,
the lights, everything's working before we
give 'em the go to go outside.
And so we go through all those checks. It's
about a three hour process before they're
even out the door. And-and so once we're convinced
we get out; they depressurize; it allows 'em
to open up the outside door and-and out they
go.
>>unidentified voice: See the interlock thermal
cover is open. You can egress the airlock.
Remember to avoid that MMOD [unintelligible].
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible]
>>Jose Hernandez: And we do have some cameras
outside where, that we control and we see
this through cameras. You can see Danny coming
out and initiating the space walk. They always
go out in pairs of two.
You can see those yellow handles; those are
the handles that astronauts translate in.
And-and they move from-from-from module to
module with those handles.
One of the things that we do is since we don't
have cameras everywhere, we do put cameras
on their helmets and that way we can see what
they're doing with respect to the work that
they're doing.
You can see here Danny's taking a picture
of himself right now.
[laughter]
And-and, but-but it's-it's actually good way
of us keeping track of what work they're doin'.
And then when they have to move long distances
or we have to take a lot of equipment with
'em, what we do is we attach 'em to the end
of the robotic arm. And Kevin Ford and I were
the ones that were operating the arm while
they were conducting their space walks. So
we would move 'em from place to place.
And during that process you would stop and
you would see just amazing scenery, but of
course you gotta continue working as-as we
went.
And I mentioned that we, you-you go around
the world every 90 minutes; that means you
have 45 minutes of daylight; 45 minutes of
nighttime. Just because it becomes nighttime
we don't stop working. We just ask the astronauts
to turn on their helmet lights and as they
turn on their helmet lights they can continue
working through the night.
And-and-and then once daylight shows up again
then they can turn off their-their helmet
lights and they continue their work.
But-but it's certainly a-a long process. It's
about seven hours during a space walk.
So these guys after-after that's done we let
'em back in and-and what we try to do is we
try to extract them out of the space suits
for as quickly as we can.
They've been in the space suit for three hours
for prep and then seven hours out there; that's
10 hours. They haven't eaten anything; they
do have a camel bag of water that they drink.
And I'm guessing if they did drink it I'm
guessing they gotta go to the restroom. So
we try to get 'em out of there as, as quickly
as we can.
And then we clean up the suits and get 'em
ready for the next space walk 'cause they
conducted a total of three-three space walks.
Between three of the astronauts, Nicole, Danny
Olivas, and Christer Fuglesang, who's a Swedish
astronaut, they did that.
Now while they're doing their space walks,
other astronauts are doing other things throughout
the mission. And one of the things is we're
transferring that, those seven tons of material.
Here-here you see is a treadmill. Remember
Colbert wanted the naming rights of a module?
[laughter]
Well, guess what? NASA wasn't about to give
him a whole module so we did the next best
thing. We actually christened that the Colbert
Treadmill so --
[laughter]
so he got a treadmill named after him. And
there's a little sticker in there that actually
has his picture on there. But --
[laughter]
but-but-but-but yeah we-we did name it after
him. We installed it and-and-and for the astronauts
to have an additional piece of equipment to
exercise.
And then we moved in the mat, the stuff that
belonged to Tim Kopra into the MPLM because
he was gonna come home with us.
And then after emptying the-the front contents
of the racks we rotate the racks and guess
what there's a whole bunch of other equipment
on the back side that we have remove.
And we have to put things in the right order.
There's a big effort in housekeeping on the
International Space Station. In other words,
whenever they say put this in this compartment,
it's gotta be there because if you can't find
it, it's like looking for a needle in a haystack.
And then we use our feet as hands 'cause obviously
we don't walk on in space so we sort of use
it in novel ways to transport. Like right
there he's transporting food trays from the
MPLM to the International Space Station.
And then once we make some room, we have some
fun. It wouldn't be space if you couldn't
have fun. And here Nicole and I are just enjoying
the free space. Then I get this bright idea,
I see these bungee cords there and I say,
"Come here, Nicole." And then I push her and
I say, "Let me get this on film."
[laughter]
Einstein was right; for every action there
is an equal and opposite reaction.
[laughter]
And then we're not supposed to play with-with
food, but we got an exception here so that
we can make our space eyeball. It's a Lifesaver
with water and Nicole, I mean and Tim Kopra
takes care of it.
[laughter]
Okay, no self righteous Mexican would do this
to a tortilla: peanut butter on one side and
jelly on the other but --
[laughter]
but it was Kevin Ford our pilot so we let
him, we let him do it, but actually it tasted
pretty good. I tasted it.
Our-our Commander Marine gets a haircut every
three days whether he needs it or not.
[laughter]
And then you wonder about hygiene. This is
how we take showers and stuff; shampoo our
hair we just put the shampoo on-on the hair,
get a towel, rub it in, and dry it off, and
we're good to go.
When we take showers we just wet the towel
and we do what's called a cowboy shower, just
wet ourselves and then there.
You need a Ph.D. to see why this thing rotates
back and forth like that, but it's pretty
interesting. Kevin Ford tried to explain to
me I couldn't get it. So I said, "Well do
it to me, see if that happens to me." But
unfortunately it didn't work out like that.
[laughter]
But it was fun, though and nevertheless it
was fun rotating like that. I said, "Let me
film it on camera just so you guys can appreciate
that perspective." And if you are wondering,
yes I did get dizzy.
[laughter]
And then here-here I am at the robotics work
station. Now I'm de-installing the MPLM and
we're gonna install it back into the payload
bay.
And-and-and then the very last night that
all 13 of us are together we have dinner together
for the very first time. We usually we had
dinner at different times since we were so
busy. And of course there's a, it's international
food. We had Mexican food, American, Russian
food, French food, and it was just a good
feast that we had that day.
And of course some people like to show off
their food eating skills; other people shouldn't
show it off.
[laughter]
The sad thing is he had been up there the
longest.
[laughter]
There you see us toasting, drinking water
because it's from our urine processing assembly
system. So yes, we do drink our urine and
I promise it tastes just like water.
[laughter]
There you see Nicole Stott saying good bye
because this is the, this is the last time
we're gonna see her. She stays on the Station
side; we stay on the, on-on-on the Discovery
side and we close our doors and this allows
us to initiate the undocking sequence.
And believe it or not this little button is
the one that does it all.
>>unidentified voice: Looks good.
>>Jose Hernadez: It initiates the sequence
and then it initiates a process that is slow
as molasses on a cold day where you then start
separating yourself from the International
Space Station.
And actually the springs on the docking mechanism
once you undo the hooks provide the initial
push for us to separate. We try not to fire
the jets a lot since we're right next to the
Station. We don't want the plumes to contaminate
our solar panels. And so we-we just try to
minimize, use the small jets and minimize
our movement.
And like I said it takes about an hour or
so too for us to fully come out to a position
where we can actually use the normal jets.
And-and during that time I'm-I'm-I'm staffing
the computers that are giving us all the rendezvous
information rates, distances, and trajectory
and feeding that information to our-our pilot
who is now at the controls of the Shuttle
and-and-and watching our separation.
In about-about 20 minutes you'll see us be
about 20-30 feet away and which is about there
and in about 15-20 more minutes we get a couple
hundred feet away and we get a full view of
the International Space Station.
At that point we begin our own circular maneuver
around the International Space Station, because
now it's our turn to take high resolution
pictures of the whole Station.
The engineers on the ground are gonna go ahead
and-and look at these pictures; make sure
there's no micro-meteorite orbital debris
hits on any part of the structure of the International
Space Station.
And that's the circular trajectory the one
that I'm feeding to Kevin Ford; make sure
that he's, he is indeed flying a circular
pattern around. At this point he's-he's pretty
much complete and he's happy as a clam 'cause
that was a big maneuver for him.
This then allows us to put on the-the pressure
suits because we're ready to come home now
and-and so we fire the jets; the atmospheric
captures us and all of a sudden you start
feeling gravity.
And let me tell you after being 14 days in
zero-g, gravity does suck.
[laughter]
There you see the, the-the fact that we went
25 times the speed of sound. We broke the
mock 25 barrier as we come in.
The Flight Director giving us last minute
instructions. We were waved off of Kennedy
Space Center for the second day in a row because
of bad weather. So we ended up landing at
Edwards Air Force Base.
And Eric Boe, one of our fellow astronauts,
is the Cap-Com. He's giving us all the winds,
the weather, the data, the runway number for
us to come in.
There we are at about 80-90,000 feet.
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible]
>>Jose Hernandez: Pretty soon the, the Shuttle
starts behaving like an airplane; the aerodynamic
surfaces start taking effect.
>>unidentified voice: Kevin, forward and control
of the stick at this moment.
>>Jose Hernandez: And then for about a period
of about 30 seconds our-our pilot takes control,
but the main control is our commander, he's
the one that actually lands it.
>>unidentified voice: Hear a sonic boom.
[pause]
>>unidentified voice: The late afternoon sunshine
gleaming off its thermal protection heat shield.
[pause]
>>unidentified voice: Three minutes until
touchdown. Rich Sturckow has taken back the
stick from Kevin Ford. The vortices off the
wing's very obvious. Discovery continuing
its turn around the heading alignment circle,
aligning with runway 22 at Edwards Airforce
Base.
[pause]
>>Jose Hernandez: This is the --
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible] landing
gear
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible]. Thank
you Jose.
>>Jose Hernandez: This is the perspective
of the, of the pilots using the Heads Up Display,
HUD display. That's what they're looking at
right now.
They're making the final turn onto to final
and that green line you see there that is
the runway. It's highlighted right now, and
it's steep. It looks like we're goin' straight
into it.
At this point you're about 10,000 feet, 300
miles an hour is what it says right there.
And you see the runway there. You're coming
in at a pretty steep angle. You do what's
called a "flare maneuver."
>>unidentified voice: Very nice. You did [unintelligible]
>>unidentified voice: Yep.
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible]
>>Jose Hernandez: You see the speed brakes
are out.
>>unidentified voice: Speed brakes right at
50. [unintelligible] Slow lag, down to the
[unintelligible], 400 [unintelligible] give
us --
>>Jose Hernandez: Very important not to forget
the gear.
[laughter]
>>unidentified voice: [unintelligible]
>>Jose Hernandez: And you can see how C.J.
Sturckow, our commander, lands this. I mean
look at the back wheels they just touch at
the same time. So he's-he's a good Marine
pilot.
[pause]
Look at that.
He brings the nose down. Once we have a delayed
shoot deploy; once the nose gear comes down
they deploy the chute to start slowing us
down a bit more. This then allows C.J. to
put the brake pedals and come to a full stop.
When he announces, "Full stop," that's when
they stop the stop watch and-and the official
end of the mission is recorded at that time.
>>unidentified voice: Houston Discovery wheel
stop.
>>unidentified voice: Copy. Wheels stop. Welcome
home, Discovery. Congratulations on an extremely
successful mission, stepping up science to
a new level on the International Space Station.
>>Jose Hernandez: And let me tell you, four
hours later after that we were in [Boron]
at Domingo's. I was, I had a beer in my hand
and --
[laughter]
and eating carne asada so it was pretty good.
It was pretty cool.
So-so-so that's how, that's sort of like the
summary of a typical mission to the International
Space Station is.
[applause]
And certainly --
certainly like I said, just to summarize what-what
I've talked about is the fact that it-it was
nice to be able to realize a dream, but it
certainly wasn't something that where I'd
say, "Hey I did this myself." I had a lot
of help as you could saw from my, the way
I spoke about how I became an astronaut. Anecdotally
I had help from my parents, my teachers, friends,
colleagues, and a little bit of per-perseverance.
So 12 times is a lot of times to apply and
to want it, but figure if you want it bad
enough you keep doing it and-and it certainly
did, wasn't hurting my career so it wasn't
like I thought I was wasting my time during
the application process.
So thank you very much.
>>Mario: Well thank you. Thank you very much
to Jose --
[applause]
for being here today.
So we do have a lot of questions from Dory
and I'm sure you have questions. To be honest
he particularly has to fly fairly soon. So
we'll try to keep it short, maybe ask one
or two questions from Dory and maybe one or
at most two live. So if you want to line up
and keep it short.
So the first question from someone in Mountainview
called John R., he says, "How do you feel
about the fact that since the Apollo program
ended we've never gone beyond low-low air
orbit? Do you think that's sufficient for
a national space program or should we press
for more manned space exploration, return
to more Mars perhaps?
>>Jose Hernandez: Yeah, I think I-I think
he's right in a sense that-that we've only
got three missions left for the Space Shuttle
Fleet and then they're gonna get retired.
What that does is that frees up resources
for us to invest in-in-in technology that's
gonna allow us to go beyond lower earth orbit.
It does us no good to just go to the moon
and cool our heels there. We wanna be able
to make sure we can also go all the way to
Mars.
For that we need advanced propulsion systems;
we need radiation protection; and-and we also
need to-to learn how to live long duration
in a zero-g environment away from the protection
of the earth's magnetic field with respect
to radiation. So-so-so yeah I think we're
heading that direction.
>>Mario: So Stacy from Mountainview she says,
"I'm a daughter of a proud Kennedy Space Center
employee and have seen many Shuttle launches
in my lifetime. I'm saddened by the decision
to end the Shuttle program. Why don't you
tell us the decision and its im, and its impact
on Florida as a space coast?
>>Jose Hernandez: Yeah, I mean it's the equivalent
when we the-the-there's no denial that in
ending the space program the Shuttle space
program, there's gonna be a shift of talent
that's needed within NASA.
In other words, the operations side of maintaining
the Shuttle, prepping it for a launch, and
refurbishing the Shuttle, those tasks aren't
gonna be needed. So there is gonna be some-some
type of human resources let go with respect
to the fact that that's what's not needed
now.
But at the same time the budget of NASA's
actually going up so the work force is not
really gonna go down, it's just gonna be a
shift of a different type of work force.
And-and it's basically the same thing that
happened between the-the era of the Apollo
and the Space Shuttle Mission. If you see
the history during Apollo when we cancelled
Apollo there was a big drop in the number
of folks needed on the operation side. And
then when the Shuttle came back when we brought
the Shuttle to life, those people were picked
up and-and then you had a real vibrant work
force.
I mean same thing's gonna happen with retiring
the Shuttle. There's gonna be a dip at Kennedy
Space Center 'cause they're more primary operations
oriented, but when we get the architecture
defined and built then the work force is gonna
steadily go back up.
>>Mario: Yeah Jose, well thank you very much
for share all this with us. We are really
happy and it was great seriously. We wanna
give you this --
>>Jose Hernandez: Oh, thank you very much.
>>Mario: gift; token of our appreciation.
Thank you very much for being here with Google.
>>Jose Hernandez: Thank you.
>>Mario: I think those guys are very happy
with your messages and just wanna let you
know that we got some T-shirts that it's a
raffle, right?
>>2Gonzalo Begazo: Yeah, so we're gonna email
the winners. [unintelligible]
Mario: Yeah.
>>Jose Hernandez: And just so, just so he
make sure he gives out the right amount I
think I signed six of 'em alright so --
[laughter]
make sure he gives away six.
>>Gonzalo Begazo: Yeah, yeah.
[laughter]
We're gonna sell one on EBay.
>>Jose Hernandez: Exactly.
>>Mario: Well thank you very much; appreciate
it; appreciate it.
[applause]
>>Gonzalo Begazo: Thanks, guys.